Veamos que sucede con las expresiones algebraicas
que incluyen multiplicación de fracciones.
Supongamos que tenemos "a" sobre "b"
por "c" sobre "d".
¿A qué es igual esto?
Te invito a que le pongas pausa al video e
intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta.
Bien, al multiplicar fracciones simplemente
se multiplican los numeradores
y se multiplican los denominadores.
Los numeradores son "a" y "c", así que al
multiplicarlos resulta que el numerador es
"a" por "c", que se escribe simplemente "ac"
y eso sobre el denominador,
que es el producto de "b" por "d",
resultado en "b" por... "b" por... "d"...
¿Qué pasaría si estuviéramos dividendo
en vez de multiplicando?
En este caso tendríamos "a" sobre "b" dividido...
dividido entre "c" sobre "d".
Y esto, ¿a qué es igual?
Nuevamente te invito a que le pongas pausa
al video e intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta.
Bien, cuando haces la división entre una fracción,
eso equivale a la multiplicación por su recíproco,
así es que, esto es igual a "a" sobre "b"...
"a" sobre "b"...
por el recíproco de "c" sobre "d", que es "d" sobre...
déjame ponerlo mejor con el mismo color que
tiene originalmente...
"d" sobre "c"...
"a" sobre "b" por "d" sobre "c".
Así como arriba.
De hecho, no debería haber usado este símbolo,
pues esto, ahora que estamos en álgebra,
se puede confundir con una "x", lo voy a indicar
con un punto, como se hace en álgebra.
Así es que "a" sobre "b" que multiplica a
"d" sobre "c" y esto es igual a, como ya sabemos,
esto es igual a "ad" sobre...
sobre "bc".
Hagamos otro.
Hagamos otro digamos un poco más complicado
y veamos si tú puedes resolverlo.
Supongamos que tenemos, no sé, déjame escribirlo
como 1 sobre "a" menos 1 sobre "b"
y todo eso sobre "c" y vamos a complicar un poco
más la expresión y eso vamos a dividirlo...
vamos a dividirlo entre 1/d.
Es una expresión más complicada que las
que hemos visto,
pero ya contamos con lo elementos para resolverla.
Te invito que le pongas pausa al video y veas
si puedes resolver esto
para obtener una sola expresión equivalente.
Bien, hagámoslo paso a paso.
Empecemos con 1/"a" menos 1/"b", calculemos
primero cual es el valor de esta expresión.
Ya sabemos como simplificar esto, empecemos
encontrando el común denominador.
Hagámoslo acá arriba.
Tenemos 1/"a" menos 1/"b" y esto es igual...
empezamos aquí multiplicando por "b" tanto
el numerador como el denominador, para obtener
"b"´sobre "b" entre "a",
no he cambiado el valor de 1 entre "a"
lo he multiplicado por "b" sobre "b"
y aquí vamos a multiplicar por "a"
el numerador y el denominador,
nos va a dar -a/"ab" o "ba" y la razón por la que hice esto es tener un común denominador
para poder hacer la diferencia, esto es igual a "b" menos "a" sobre y el denominador lo puedo escribir como "ba"
o "ab",  así que esto va a ser igual a...
esto es igual a, 1 entre "a" menos 1 entre "b",
acabamos de ver que es "b" menos "a"
sobre "ab" y esto lo tenemos que dividir entre "c",
lo cual es lo mismo que multiplicar por
el recíproco de "c", dividir entre "c",
es lo mismo que multiplicar por el recíproco
de "c", que es igual a 1/"c".
Y aquí, continuando con el desarrollo, tenemos
una división entre 1 entre "d", lo cual fíjate,
aquí tuvimos una división entre "c", fue
lo mismo que multiplicar por 1/"c",
ahora tenemos una división entre 1/"d", que es lo mismo que multiplicar por el recíproco
de "d", así es que esto por "d"/1.
Y esto es igual a... en el numerador tenemos
el producto de "b" menos "a" por 1 por "d",
que es igual a "d" que multiplica a "b" menos "a"...
"d" que multiplica a "b" menos "a"...
y en el denominador tenemos "a" por "b" por "c".
Así es que entre "abc".
Finalmente, vamos a aplicar aquí la propiedad
distributiva para este producto de "d" por "b" menos "a",
así es que esto es igual...
y aquí yo creo que merecemos una pequeña fanfarria...
Esto es igual a "d" que multiplica a "b" menos "d"...
no, lo voy a poner con el mismo verde...
menos "d" por "a" y eso dividido entre "a" por "b" por "c".
Y así hemos concluido.